All right, let's go to the phones.
A lot
of people want to get on today at six one
seven, eight three zero 47 50.
Let's go.
Let's talk to Tim in the six three one.
Tim in the six three one.
What's new with you, Tim?
We haven't heard from you in the new year.
Are you David?
Hey, what's up?
Uh, just want to give you a quick call, uh,
to get your take on the new owner with video
that came out, uh, the undercover video of
a Bernie Sanders staffer in Iowa talking about
how Trump's reporters should be in quoted
being in putting gulags and how gulags are
a good thing and they should be shown on the
beach.
Yeah, I'm against that.
I saw the video.
Obviously, this is no, you know, this is no
Bernie strategist or anything like that, but
I find that attitude.
I find what was said absolutely denounced
Sibel and deplorable.
Uh, you know, in the United States we have
a due process.
We don't put people in prison or jail for
political beliefs and that is not something
I can get behind for sure.
That's good to hear.
Um, you know, I've seen Bernie Sanders career
and it's on video that he has talked highly
of Fidel Castro's attack, this, uh, dealing
with dissidence.
Again, shooting them on the beach and he is
for that.
Hold on, let me back.
Hold on a second.
Let's back up with Tim.
I want to make sure, I know you're saying
you've seen video of Bernie saying he approves
of shooting dissidents on a beach with guns.
No, no, no, no, no.
I said that he promotes Fidel Castro and the
Castro family and their climb to power.
Oh, I haven't heard Bernie ever do that.
I can't, I'm not saying that, that's not something
he said.
I'm just saying that I'm not aware of him
having said that.
Okay.
Well, just as data, their interviews back
in the 1980s anyone can look them up and there's
also him stating that bred lines are a good
thing.
You know, people either die in the streets
or are rich, which isn't realistically plausible.
Um,
sorry, hold on.
I don't, I don't, I don't mean to keep interrupting
you, Tim, but you're talking so quickly that
I want to make sure you're, did you just say
Bernie said that he's fine with people either
being rich or dying in the streets?
No.
The first part, again, I said he was fine.
He likes bread lines.
He thinks bread lines are a good thing.
Quote in quote.
Okay.
I've never seen him say that.
I don't know what the source of that is.
No.
If you, if you type in YouTube and it's not
centered yet, Bernie Sanders States that bread
lines are a good thing.
Well, who would sensor that?
What do you mean?
He made his interview?
I'm talking about YouTube and Google algorithms.
They [inaudible] the video.
Hold on.
You're saying that you
search,
Oh, hold on a second, Tim.
I'm trying to understand you're, you're saying
YouTube would make the video not find-able
or they would delete the video,
right?
I would say, I'm not sure if it is yet, but
they would maybe not the wheat, the video,
they would take it out of search results.
So if you're typing in the search bar in YouTube
or Google, because they're basically the same
thing at this point, they can remove that
and put the mainstream media up on top of
that.
So things from CNN, things from Fox news,
vice versa, a recommendation from Fox news.
You've seen this?
I only get Fox news and I hate it.
Okay.
Yeah, no, there's no question that the YouTube,
YouTube algorithm is definitely designed to
prop up certain content and push down others
that die that there's no, I won't argue with
that at all, Tim.
So, so what I'm saying is for your audience
and for you as well, cause I'm not sure how
you haven't seen this, is that he States that
Bernie Sanders state that bread lines are
a good thing in a country.
You know, not having seen the video, which
I look for.
I would, I would guess knowing Bernie that
there's more context than you're providing.
That's my guest.
But I'll review the video.
Tim, I appreciate you bringing it to my attention.
That'd be great.
And thanks for having me on again, David.
It's always good talking with you.
All right, very good.
There is Tim.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
49 area code color from nine four nine.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Uh, this is Daniel from Los Angeles.
Hey Daniel.
What part of LA are you calling from?
Uh, downtown LA, actually.
Downtown.
Okay.
Not, I know, I kind of like downtown.
I know it gets a bad rap.
Downtown is great and it's got really revitalized
as long as you don't mind walking past a bunch
of homeless shelters.
Well, yeah, and we talked about that actually
earlier this weekend and some of the policies
that are, that are being considered there,
but in any case, this is your time, not mine.
What did you want to talk about today?
Uh, well I did want to touch on the previous
callers, a little conversation about the,
uh, the bread lines comment.
Uh, the context that you were looking for
is that he was saying in other countries,
people don't line up for food.
The rich get the food and the poor starve
to death.
So versus starving to death, bread lines are
a good thing.
I see.
Okay.
Well that is, that is relevant context.
I would say having to wait in line for bread
seems better than starving to death.
Most definitely.
The thing I wanted to touch bases one on is
there's all this trial going on with Trump,
the impeachment, and there are a lot of officials
who are getting involved and basically just
blocking things and trying to make it so there
are no witnesses, there's no evidence reviewed
or anything like that.
At what point are these people, I understand
that we're hoping that they'll be held politically
responsible in the upcoming elections at one
point.
Does it get to where they would be held criminally
responsible?
Both for aiding and abetting and president?
Never.
Right?
Yeah.
Nope.
Never.
That's disappointing.
I mean, listen, you know, if you in a, there
are people who would argue that that's a good
thing.
So [inaudible] one of the prototypical examples
is my home country of Argentina where it is
very common that when you have a change of,
of regime, the new regime will start.
Um, uh, we'll, we'll, we'll assist in and
we'll push for criminal charges against members
of the prior regime.
And the thing is, if you've done something
criminal, you should be, uh, there should
be consequences for that.
You should be held accountable.
And of course, the problem becomes when it
just becomes this circle where every regime
starts getting indictments on the previous
regime, nothing is ever resolved.
Kangaroo courts, you know, all this, it, it,
it's a, it's a catch 22 situation because
I want people held accountable.
I've also seen what happens when an administration
simply starts indicting members of the previous
one endlessly.
It's not particularly good for the country
because before you know it, the previous people
are back in power, much like is happening
in Argentina now.
So it's, I don't know what the solution is
quite frankly.
Well, just to follow on that point in regards
to, uh, when Obama got elected and decided
that we were going to look forward and not
prosecute people who were potentially guilty
of war crimes, um, who had just left office.
Was that a good decision?
Cause I feel like that just re, you know,
encouraged, uh, a certain party to continue
down that line.
Yeah.
Any time to some degree, anytime one gets
away with something, it is an it, it is a
tacit, uh, encouragement to do something again
the next time or it sets an example for someone
else to some degree.
Obviously the world is more complicated than
that, but you have to balance it with wood.
If Obama says we're going to indict a, well,
of course Obama couldn't, couldn't say it
because he doesn't control the judiciary.
But let's say the Obama administration and
his judiciary decided we're going to investigate
and indict George W. Bush on war crimes if
it's the right thing in many cases.
But what happens in the United States to the
fabric of the relationship between all of
these different branches?
I'm not saying it wouldn't be warranted, but
where would we be today if that had been done?
Because [inaudible] is Bush going to go to
prison for that?
Of course not.
So what do we really achieve by doing it?
I don't know.
I want people held accountable, but I know
that's not the way they're going to be.
Right.
No, that's a good point.
Well, thank you for your time today, David.
All right, Daniel, great to hear from you.
Appreciate it.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
Oh six area code.
Who is calling today from seven zero six.
Oh, Hey David.
This is Kyle from Orlando, Florida.
Hey Kyle.
What's up?
Hey.
Um, so, uh, I work for Disney and, um, as
part of our union contract, we were able to
get a $15 an hour, uh, by 2021.
Right.
Um, which I think is great, but, um, you know,
in 2016 we were having the debate about $15
being the minimum wage.
Uh, but you know, given that inflation is
a thing, uh, shouldn't we be talking about
$20 an hour now?
And tying that to inflation.
Yeah.
So this is something that I've mentioned many
times when the $15 an hour minimum wage thing
started, and it was often not for right now,
but let's get up to $15 by some future date.
A lot of the [inaudible]
outreach, a lot of the outrage was just bad
faith outrage.
Some of the outrage seemed not to take into
account that merely because of inflation,
it would have really only been like $12 at
the time that the conversation started, or
$13 at the time that, you know, the conversation's
been going on at a lot of different be tied
to, to inflation automatically because otherwise
this conversation will literally never end.
Right, right.
The, I mean, do you think like shooting for
$20 an hour anyways, and then, I mean, maybe
we can say, Oh, well the compromise will be,
you know, $15 an hour.
Um, just as a way to, I guess to get ahead
of the Republicans.
I don't know that I would just
throw out a random number, but there are good
studies that say, listen, if we had indexed
to inflation going back to 1968, it should
now be, you know, like 1770 an hour.
That's where it should be.
Let's negotiate from there.
And, and here's something that now a lot of
people on the right won't, won't like that,
but let me say something that a lot of people
on the left won't like, which I think does
make sense.
I've said before
four, I think that the minimum wage needs
to be regionalized to some degree because
if you have a low cost of living state where
you're talking about going from seven 50 to
15, that is very different than a high cost
of living state where you're talking about
going from 12 to 15.
So I do think that there is something too
we should look at.
I don't know if it's on a state by state level,
Metro areas or whatever the case may be, but
there should be consideration given to both
cost of living, uh, as well as, um, uh, what
the, the current minimum wage is.
I'm not advocating for the wage to be seven
25 anywhere to be clear, but I am saying that
in some places, 15 may not actually be the
right number to achieve what it is that, that
we should be looking to achieve.
Okay.
Well thanks David.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.